I unfair Mata Jana I am from Madrid
Spain do you want my job title or do you
want my general so they say I'm 30 years
old and I work in the film and TV
production industry in the UK and I'm
here today with tone Ford and CQ GQ
thank you you know that because you're a
Leo what kind of clothes will you wear
what kind of car will you drive where
will you live you're gonna be dating so
in five years you're gonna be a producer
you are a Leo very definitely a Leo very
very confident in fact while we were
shooting him he's had something really
funny he said they tell me my profiles
are good and he immediately sort of
struck a a profile shot which was
hysterical
but these rights profile was pretty
great he brought some pieces of
outerwear all the outerwear was were in
earth tones but it was the most deadly
shades of olive and kind of ashy Browns
and when Tom put the brown shearling
jacket on him you know he just owned it
he hasn't exfoliated since I was born
their skin hanging on there from 1948 we
trimmed his beard I liked his beard I
think it looks great with a beard his
his beard was a little longer in certain
spots they want to sort of just even it
down but still a full beard not just
stubble just like a really groomed beard
differentiating your beard from your
neck gives you a very strong jawline so
it just makes you neat and clean
you know his hair color is beautiful
coffee color and his skin is tan so by
putting him in that same color tone it
just made him even more handsome they
look a little small on you but also they
need to be they step in your jeans are
way too short I didn't look after myself
as much as I should
from from that point of view I were a
jumper or maybe a hoody a jumper is like
a good hoodie without a hoodie yeah yeah
there you are looking like a model yeah
great
sometimes if you're wearing something
like a very rich dark brown and you put
brown and brown and brown and your skin
is brown and your hair is brown it could
feel a little heavy and so you know
putting white with it sets it off and
and it isn't heavy oh that's good that's
beautiful that's beautiful of head shape
and angles perfect
don't move excellent gorgeous I like the
way you're just staring down the camera
one thing that I learned from Tom today
it's to be very professional on top of
every single detail